les chéris avant-hier patrick timsit
était l'invité de quotidien voilà moi je
suis aux jauges de dire j'ose dire c'est
le nom de cette émission messieurs et
gestes pas dire non
et lors de son interview je ne sais pas
ce qui lui a pris me s'est acharné sur
notre émission sans aucune raison et sur
le pauvre benjamin castaldi
pourtant à chaque fois qu'il est venu
est d'ailleurs clément garin l'excellent
mon clément mon ami clément
il a recensé sur twitter les venue de
patrick timsit invités ppd 23 octobre
2012 26 mars 2013 21 janvier 2014
9 décembre 2014 4 décembre 2017 26
février 2018 il a mis no comments et je
vous propose de regarder ce qu'il a dit
et c'est vrai que je crois que ça vous a
peiné alors moi je m'en fous totalement
patrick timsit personnellement voilà je
m'en fous un peu
mais je sais que pour ça vous a peiné
mais on va l'appeler on va la prendre
répond à trèbes rares 6 m/s
c'est un habitué des dérapages que ce
soit en plateau dans ses spectacles
patrick timsit a une nouvelle fois
franchi la ligne jaune
les mongoliens c'est comme les crevettes
roses à part la tête tout est bon
lundi soir alors invité deux quotidiens
dans l'émission de yann barthès patrick
timsit a voulu lire quelques vannes de
son nouveau spectacle en plateau alors
il paraît que vous êtes venu un peu avec
votre ordinateur pour tester des vannes
sur nous et il semblerait que l'homme
ait eu un petit excès de zèle en voulant
complètement dénigrer tpm p une émission
dans laquelle il a été convié à
plusieurs reprises sans l'émission de
cyril hanouna sans sonore nuisances
visuelles sa plus belle truie de
neurones un tacle qui ne s'arrête pas là
puisqu'il s'en est aussi pris à un des
chroniqueurs j'ai rencontré benji je
suis dit mais pourquoi tu fais là comme
j'aime les plus bas la crau une valse
que ça ça me permet de faire des choses
de qualité à côté quoi tout n'est pas
morose mais c'est quoi cette merde si
les salles de spectacle devrait rouvrir
après la pandémie faut-il encore bosser
les vannes pour les remplir
patrick timsit at il une nouvelle fois
dérapé patrick dit alors je vous dis sur
les réseaux sociaux il s'est fait
défoncer c'est moi ou patrick timsit est
hyper lourd et genot pas très drôle le
gars ou alors j'ai plus d'humour il est
bien content d'y aller quand c'était la
seule émission qui voulait le recevoir
tu étais plus drôle avant patrick timsit
heureusement que c'est ton dernier
spectacle c'est un peu la mode de casser
à droite à gauche quand
professionnellement c'est le néant total
faut bien chercher un peu le boss je
pense qu'il a voulu faire un buzz moi et
scélérat mais je vais faire un buzz en
parlant de tpm pêche et les voilages
vécu le truc en plus qui fait jour il
trouve sur son ordinateur un passage
alors qu'on avait tout prévu avant
guillaume ben franchement c'est
n'importe quoi il a le droit tacler tpp
de la droite dans les actes gratuits et
hypocrite si l'émission issue si nul que
ça pourquoi il vient et pourquoi quand
il est là il dit rien c'est ça qui est
hypocrite en fait non moi je trouve ça
me déçoit celui-ci n'est pas venu depuis
des années il connaît même pas les
missions auprès des jeunes et avec anne
nivat alors je trouve ça laurent petit
forceps quand même pas n'importe qui
s'adapte de manière mais ce qu'il a fait
depuis un indien dans la ville non à
l'ours et son célèbre frère s'affaissant
temps qu'il a rien fait et patrick will
voilà donc ils cherchent à tout prix
quelqu'un ou quelque chose qui pourrait
lui donner un peu de notoriété mais si
la peine
il n'est plus rien aujourd'hui bah oui
oui voila moi ce qui me gêne beaucoup
c'est le double langage effectivement il
vient ici faire sa promo et puis après
ils balancent derrière ça c'est ma vie à
chaque fois qu'ils viennent demander
c'est exactement son finnois là bas ça
m'étonne pas et en plus qui est
dégueulasse et pour tous les
téléspectateurs bien ça c'est mes prix
lui qui se veut un homme populaire il
méprise tous les ans qui vous regardent
qui regardent l'émission
moi je suis plus choqué ce qu'il connaît
même pas je pense qu'il n'a jamais
regardé les michel puis des 10 rue et
yann barthès qui se marchent stupidement
à côté sinon si on ferait alors vouloir
non là je suis pas d'accord nicolas
pernikoff non alors moi en fait ce qui
m'a le plus dérangé c'est la mise en
scène c'est à dire soit disant déroule
un procès et on prend un exemple à on va
tout d'un coup regarder un petit extrait
du spectacle et à on tombe pile poil à
sûreté pmp suranné à machin d'autres
comme par hasard et à un moment donné je
sens quand même les gens gêné c'est dire
que le rien même de barthez on le sent
pas complètement assurée malaisie
en l'occurrence et après dire c'est une
merde la loi dire ce qu'il veut mais il
ya aujourd'hui et c'est toujours la même
histoire
plus d'un million six cent mille
téléspectateurs qui suivent ils sont de
plus en plus nombreux tpm p je trouve ça
irrespectueux
je ne pense pas qu ici on est par les
démissions de merde quand on parle du
métier oui mais on est grand il a voulu
faire du buzz on ne peut plus parler de
lui depuis pas mal de temps mais remet
un peu dépressif à l'histoire
je pense qu'il ya un peu des prêteurs
isabelle alors il est comédien à la télé
honnêtement c'est un bon comédien mais
justement il est plus comique et là dans
l'émission de yann barthès je trouve que
c'est particulièrement mesquin
honnêtement d'aller dénigrer une
émission qui plaisait dans une émission
rival qui a exactement le un talk show
et je trouve que ça ne se fait pas tout
bêtement alors on leur vitesse et le
lendemain pour qu'ils viennent voilà ici
il a même pas répondu sachez le bon
c'est vrai que patrick timsit et le
courage ça fait 2-1 et sa team petit je
sais que demain je vais le croiser dans
la rue je pense que l'accord va chier
dans son froc non mais c'est vrai mais
ce qu'il ya c'est que en fait au-delà de
tous à la polémique tpm pcc que s juste
qu'il n'est pas drôle du tout rsa c'est
le cas c'est que quand caen géré à six
avaient été bons on aurait on aurait ri
chanté journée les premières semaines et
scieries de me battre sur comme j'aime
quand j'ai ramé vannes soit comme m sur
rtl c'est très bien et de paris donc la
visite la seule limite ce qui est
terrible pour lui c'est voilà c'est pas
drôle du tout c'est gratuit
effectivement il joue alors je vous le
dire je vais pas vous mentir c'est
hanouna tpm paix si vous mettez ces deux
mots dans un tweet ou dans un truc c'est
sûr et certain
vous êtes vous êtes voilà monsieur voilà
tous les journalistes web tout le monde
on reprend donc c'est un coup de buzz
mais en même temps comme il fait pas
grand chose ce matin d'un festival voilà
à ramatuelle ouais mais là c'est
vraiment beaucoup de temps et on
s'occupe meurt festival à ses côtés tous
sont à prendre des cendres et en plus
quand on s'occupe d'un festival à
ramatuelle
voilà actuelle mais c'est vrai qu'un
festival arrive alors dans le coffee
dont plus loin à la pause c'est vraiment
bien donc je trouvais ça j'ai trouvé ça
nul
les mecs pendant le convie donc plus
c'est vrai que c'était beaucoup
s'expriment beaucoup et j'ai ouïe dire
franchement j'ai eu plein de gens qui
m'ont rappelé qu' on aimait le plus le
plus triste c'est que ça n'est pas un
c'est ce mec il appelle alors il est
venu le savait et moi je vous dis tout
le jeu en voyant alors je lui envoyais
d'abord de points d'interrogations après
jusmy il a l'air super drôle ton
spectacle je suis plutôt sympa un frère
ça fait 20 ans que plus drôle
profite pour retravailler fréhaut ça te
détruit des neurones c'est insultant
pour notre public et ça je laisserai pas
passer là il m'a répondu je ne
connaissais pas ton numéro tu sais c'est
de la vanne tu vas giovan
ce n'est pas plus grave que ça bonne
soirée à toi oui t'inquiète zéro souci
je ferai une réponse drôle aussi
et après aimé des jmj qui ne doit pas
comprendre et donc c'est vrai que moi
voilà c'est je me suis dit bon c'est
vrai qu'il fait il mais il m'a mois moi
je vous dire la vérité il me fais plus
d'appels côtoient voilà c'est même pas
voilà c'est ces sujets pas plus mais il
s'est aussi réjoui des années à chacun
de ses spectacles valsecchi l'émotion
l'a fait ça les dérapages mais quand à
l'époque c'était mm si après il ya eu
viol
après il ya eu les personnes handicapées
et à chaque fois ce sont des blagues de
mauvais goût et là il
j'imagine en train de se dire alors
qu'est ce qui fonctionne très très bien
aujourd'hui elle était très populaire
cyril hanouna à l'homme je vais lui
taper dessus je sais qu'après ça va être
relayée dans la presse sur internet
il a eu la réussite libre oui moi je
pense que c'est un dérapage en fait
c'est totalement calculer ce soir il va
aller faire sa promotion à quotidien et
en même temps vu qu'il doit choisir
entre quotidien où vous forcément mais
non l'avenir
a ok mais je voudrais inviter le
lendemain voilà ce que ça nous faisait
marrer d'une mère judy là en parlant de
tpm mais forcément ça allait être repris
le lendemain ici donc ça lui fait une
double promo quelque part c'est plutôt
malin en fait mais promo pour avoir pour
faire la promo il faut avoir un bon
maintenant il a promis il faut qu'il
travaille le spectacle patrick seale on
a encore les capacités vous savez il
n'ya rien de pire pour un humoriste de
son tir et rires non mais c'est vrai ça
c'est ça moi je les ai vus là je les ai
sentis même lui on voyait qu'ils
croyaient plus à ses vannes il m'a fait
il m'a fait de la peine
voilà je vous dirai ce que c'est vrai
qu'il a été drôle et voilà on parlera de
lui au passé